I want to show you guys one other clip
because uh DeSantis went hard when it
came to defending keeping Florida free
and I would also say this you mentioned
Liz that people are flocking to Florida
that would not have happened if Charlie
Chris had his way he wrote me a letter
in July of 2020 saying you need to shut
down the State of Florida he said you
need to force people to shelter in their
own homes that would have destroyed the
State of Florida that would have caused
that would have caused our tourism
industry to go into the toilet it would
have locked out millions of kids from
school I rejected Charlie Chris lockdown
letter I kept this state open and I kept
the state free and we now have the
biggest budget surplus in the history of
Florida we have a 2.5 percent
unemployment second lowest on record and
we just did the biggest tax cut in
Florida Governor that's time
Congressman you have 30 seconds for
rebuttal thank you very much Well Ron
that's rich you're the only governor in
the history of Florida that's ever shut
down our schools you're the only
governor in the history of Florida that
shut down our businesses I never did
that as Governor you're the one who's
the shutdown guy we need to have
somebody who is at the helm that
understands it's important to listen to
science to do what's right utilize
common sense you don't just shut down at
the outset and then when it's you know
politically convenient for you you want
to open back up the store political
points
Governor you have 30 seconds well so he
opposed having kids in school his
supporters sued me to keep the kids out
of school in 2020 and how critical was
that decision we just got the nation's
report card the results from all 50
states Florida number three in fourth
grade reading and number four in the
country in fourth grade math and if you
adjust that for demographic we are
number one in the country in both that
would not have happened if we let
Charlie Chris and his friends lock our
kids out of school like they did in
California and like they did in New York
we did it right in Florida Dave are you
amazed that you know we were told before
the thing started you know both sides Be
quiet which the DeSantis side did okay
the Chris side did not so then the
decent decide to start you know started
getting involved too but are you amazed
that there were people who were actually
cheering for more lockdowns I mean
people even here in Florida seem to want
more of the nonsense it it's uh look
it's crazy I I I am not sympathetic to
Charlie Crist in any way
that said he did have an impossible task
ahead of him because I mean he opened up
the debate
blasting DeSantis and saying you're the
only one governor in the history of
Florida who's locked schools down well
this is a real disconnect with his
audience and his supporters especially
the crazy people probably from the
teachers unions in his in his um in the
audience in the crowd because all of
these people love the lockdowns you know
they they they loved it so he he really
kind of had an impossible task ahead of
him because
um you've got all these contradictory
um all these contradictory ideas you
know they they want to attack DeSantis
for
um for being too heavy-handed on one
hand but on the other hand they
supported every heavy-handed thing and
more so it's a difficult place to be and
and uh look I can understand a
I guess theoretically an anti-desantis
anti-freedom position I can kind of
understand that
um I don't think it's right but it's it
makes a certain amount of sense what I
don't understand is the theory of
Charlie Chris candidacy
you know I I can understand someone
who's the anti-disantis but Pro Charlie
Crist I just don't get it because the
guy is you know I mean the guy's an
empty suit as as John said he will say
whatever it takes
um just a shell of a human